hey outs of guys my name is Archana and
welcome to episode 5 of the game
programming series season 2 so we're
back unfortunately I didn't have time
last week to make an episode but we're
hopefully back to more or less a weekly
kind of schedule here and last time
episode 4 we talked about really how the
server would receive packets and this
whole listening process and the whole
processing kind of process and I even
gave some examples in terms of the assi
database and how he would actually
handle something like you know a login
requests or something like that right so
what we're going to do today is actually
start setting up the client side because
whilst we have a lot of kind of server
stuff going on here I mean we don't have
like a lot or anything but we do have
like quite a disk what a decent kind of
start foundation for our server unless
we set up a client right now there's no
way to test any of this I mean I've told
you guys that you know we have this
listen thing that will theoretically
accept packets and we have a method here
called send which will send packets all
of that stuff is all good but we can't
test it because we need you know you
know to test networking you need to have
two things right if you have your all if
you're all alone then you can't really
test out your your your multiplayer
capabilities so what we're going to do
is we're going to create a friend for
ourselves known as the client so that we
can talk to the client and socialize and
and hopefully transmit data back and
forth so to do that I mean because our
wheat we kind of have in terms of our
project setup we have this rain project
of course which is our actual game
that's the one that we kind of care
about that's where the client is going
to reside the the server of course is a
standalone application that runs on an
actual server right so it would run on a
dedicated computer well liked it I mean
it doesn't have to run on a dedicated
computer I mean obviously you could just
run it on your same computer that you
were playing the game from and that's
fine
but what I mean is it is actually like a
standalone application that runs on its
own right it's not part of the game or
anything like that
however the client of course needs to be
part of the game because like the game
is the client so in in this rain kind of
package we have this packet we have an
package called Matt which is kind of
where I set everything up and that's
where we're going to kind of create a
new class inside in that package and I
mean I'll probably just end up calling
this client we called the server server
so it kind of makes sense to call the
client client I am going to quickly look
at server and see what we've got here
because I mean theoretically we kind of
will be taking a lot of what we have
here and putting it into our client I
mean not like in a huge kind of way
where we kind of just change absolutely
everything as in like there will be
changes that we need to implement
obviously like for example here we just
start a diagram socket with a port and
everything oh actually one thing I
should mention and I did mention this
last time is that because this is UDP
there isn't like this initial kind of
you know connection being established
right there's you know like TCP has that
whole three-way handshake kind of thing
that I'm not going to talk about UDP
doesn't have anything like that because
again going back to my incredibly
awesome mail analogy all that UDP is
about right is this like it's like kind
of you know you you have this mailbox
set up and you kind of go there and you
collect mail or you put mail in there
and then the postman comes and takes it
right it's that kind of thing way it's
just kind of you there's no guarantee of
really anything you just kind of you
have a drop-off location so most like
some like ultra kind of shady deal going
on where you where you get told to drop
off your thing or whatever it is at a
particular location and then someone
might take it someone might not take it
but you drop it off and you leave and
that's it and then you receive further
instructions right it's kind of like
that yeah that brings back memories
anyway sorry back to this so basically
in order to set this up I mean all it's
gonna be really is again real simple
kind of the same thing as the server in
terms of we establish a socket which is
like our mailbox our mailbox yeah and
then we of course can't kind of send and
receive packets let's do it when we set
up client we're gonna set up a
constructor of course which takes in a
pause
we'll assign a port to a field just like
we normally kind of do what else do we
have in our server that's really all we
did and then we have this start thing
which kind of you know did stuff so
where this is where the differences are
going to come because we're actually
going to write a function called connect
right and not only we're going to write
a function called connect we're actually
also going to write an address into our
into our client here now the reason I'm
doing this is not keep in mind because
suddenly there is going to be like an
official kind of connection thing that
we run no the actual low-level kind of
API in terms of the parts of Java's API
that we use for this are indeed going to
be identical to the server
it's just that we're kind of simulating
like out where we're creating our own
kind of connection situation right
because of course we do kind of
theoretically from a high level we do
need to establish a connection even if
the low like if the low level doesn't
support that we'll have to add on that
functionality because you know from an
abstract kind of high level point of
view we require it excuse me
so let's do that the other thing I'll
quickly do by the way because this is
gonna get a bit annoying is so we'll
solve the eye net address I think I
believe we I mean the server wouldn't
have had an arrest no it wouldn't have
and then when we when we did do send we
we took in the einer address thing so I
guess we'll do that and then that means
that of course when we assign address
we'll have to do ina address dot get get
my name right and then the host of
course is the address okay this will
kind of be I might actually call this
the server or the host or something
because this is kind of the host like
address right and of course that will
kind of throw exceptions to rule will
handle that and of course what will um
I'm not even sure if me maybe should do
that here it might be worth doing it
when we actually decide to connect
because of course that
establishing connection yeah okay we're
actually gonna move this down so we will
still store string as will say IP
address and port okay and then we'll
just say this dot IP address not that we
need the this in this case but anyway
this YP address equals horse and it's
all particles port and then of course
when we do here that's where we'll
actually attempt to establish that thing
so the reason I've done that is because
I don't want the constructor of client
to start throwing all these exceptions
and everything right you shouldn't be
doing that Connect is when we actually
do stuff by constructing a client all
you are doing and all you should be
doing is basically setting up your data
right you're setting up your parameters
that's it you're not actually doing
anything like validating the IP address
which is what we're about to do here
right so I kind of want to ensure that
I'm maintaining some kind of level of of
order around here so we'll say IP um
we'll say okay so we will need an actual
inet address I'll call it serve address
probably so server address equals and we
have that yep server address equals I
net address get by name and then our
host of course is this IP address that's
gonna throw an exception but no worries
we'll surround that with try and cash
and handle that so of course I'm gonna
be really simple with this I'm gonna
return a boolean there is a problem
we're going to basically return false if
you wanted to you could maintain some
kind of error code I guess I should
probably because we're trying to make
good programmers here I mean just to
show you guys something that you can set
up it's kind of really easy is we could
have an enum called era or something
right and then we're gonna have like you
know none and you could theoretically
return this instead of a boolean but I
kind of like returning a boolean and
said it doesn't matter so we'll have
none we'll have like invalid hearts
we'll have so invalid Hearst let's see
in front think of a good way described
the lack of connection in that Hearst
okay we'll come to it I don't know yeah
I don't know I don't know invalid
connection seems like a weird term I'll
probably think of something as I
continue but basically if this happens
of course our white of that I mentioned
it this of course will print stacktrace
kind of on debug builds I guess and then
we'll also what we'll do is we'll have a
private error error code or something
which will be equal to aerodrome on by
default of course and then I guess we'll
set the error code for example here to
invalid host okay this is one way of
doing it you could all you could
obviously also make it so that you
return an error and then you could check
to see if error doesn't equal error like
if error doesn't equal Aaron on it means
you've got an error okay so that's not
another thing you could do up to you I'm
just showing you guys kind of different
ways to think about this okay so we've
got several dress it up I will do the
thing that we always do which is which
is set up the what's are called our
diagram softest so we have our socket
I keep commenting stuff so we have our
socket of course which will be a new
diagram socket of course we're gonna set
that up on our port and this will throw
its own kind of Sonic's exception so
this again is maybe something you might
want to handle I don't know I'll keep it
simple for now and man I've stopped
doing that how do I keep doing that
control control for / it seems so arrow
equals software exception
you can false I record and of course
will have something by the way that's
obviously like get error code or
something which returns that error code
maybe also we have something that just
automatically prints it as well or locks
until a file lots of things we could do
right so sue me asks I've got a setup
we're basically ready to go so we're
going to move on to kind of sending
stuff so if we have a public voice and
again this is a different situation than
the server in the server our send method
required an address because we need to
know what we're sending it to this is
the client the only the only thing the
client can connect to is a server right
the client should only be sending data
towards the server now you might have
multiple servers you might have multiple
places that you fear it if we want to
send information like for example maybe
you have maybe this isn't like a
multiplayer game obviously and so you
have your server where you send your
like positional information and actual
gameplay related stuff but then you
might also have like another server or
another set of data that you want to
send basically which is telemetry data
so for example metrics and like stuff
like that right just feel like
statistics purposes and just you know
whatever so telemetry you might want to
send obviously to one server and then
actual gameplay stuff you might want to
send to another server so yes you could
have multiple servers that being said
we're gonna assume for now that the
server you going to send to is just that
one okay that's the one that you specify
when you make the client and that's it
maybe of course if you wanted to send to
multiple servers or you wanted to you
know I guess connect to two different
servers again one for maybe like for
different purposes you could just create
two instance two instances of this
client class and theoretically that
should work okay so now that's out of
the way because of that all you really
do need to send is that byte data right
that we have like this stuff is not
quiet so we have our data to save a bit
of time I'm just gonna grab this and
copy it and paste it into here because
it's going to be identical the address
of course is going to be the host
address or the server address I called
it and what's your deal no good now okay
there was a warning
thing that was unused but of course it
isn't either they use now this is yep
okay so we have this and then the port
of course that we're going to send to
will actually not be this oh yeah this
is interesting
sorry this is where I need to actually
mention something because I've done this
wrong this port is not the port of the
client right this port is the service
port and in fact to clear that up I'm
actually going to create another
constructor that will just be like
string host which won't contain a port
and what this will do is basically
formats will be something like
192.168.1.1 column like five thousand or
something right where you basically have
this colon here and you have the whole
IP address here because that's kind of
how you want to provide it this will
basically just be like your format where
you have and maybe I'll stick this like
here or something just so that we know
there we go that is for that and then
the format for this will be my gist
right example instead and then the
format here will be basically you know
that and that so it kind of we've kind
of separated it right and that's kind of
how I gonna roll so we'll shut that down
for a bit and so what then what we'll do
here as a really simple thing of course
and we can you know put in valid host if
it fails maybe is we're going to just
basically grab the host we're going to
split it by a colon right which will
give us two values now that will
basically be other nerve parts so we
split that by that of course and we can
probably do some other kind of stuff to
verify that it's correct for example if
parts dot length doesn't equal to then
we know there's an issue so we can
probably do two things we're going to
set the error code to invalid Horace so
we are doing some kind of validation
here by the
it's just that we're not doing actual
like validation in terms of that we're
just doing very basic string validation
and return okay that's one verification
we can run of course the other one is
going to be we're going to set the IP
address two paths zero and then we're
going to set the port to integer dot
pass and pass one now if this fails
which we're going to verify so if that
throws a number formats exception we're
going to return and we're going to set
the error part again to invalid eyes all
right so we should now have the port and
the thing the port and the IP address
just from one string this time so we
don't have to provide that and woah of
course we'll test that stuff how we go
over time 16-inch minutes okay it's not
the worst thing in the world excuse me
okay let's let's let's accelerate this a
little bit so we have the socket of
course so what I'll do now is yes so
that that that's kind of where I left
off this port is the port of this isn't
correct what we actually want to do is
create a socket with just that right I
mean of course we could specify some
other port is definitely not going to be
this port I mean it could be
theoretically but it doesn't it could be
like a random port it doesn't matter
obviously like within the correct range
so it could be like that or something
that's fine if but the the point is we
don't care what port it is because this
is the client okay we just need some
kind of unused port so that we can
essentially again we just want to set up
a mailbox and then that that way we can
send data to the server since no one's
going to be connecting to us right since
no one is going to be sending us data
before we send it to them we don't need
to basically publicly set our port or IP
address for that matter right all you
need to know is the IP address of the
server when the server receives your
mail right there will be a return
address
your letter which means that the server
will be like okay I can see where this
mail came from I'll return it you know
back or I'll send my new letter back
right so an allergy aside when we when
the server receives a packet from the
client the packet will have the IP
address and the port from which that
packet came from so then when the server
wants to send the client a packet the
server can do so by sending it to the
basically to the address and port that
it retrieved from the packet that it
received from the client okay it's kind
of complicated it's really really simple
don't ever think it too much so that
being said that's kind of how that that
works so because of that we can just say
new diagram socket that will give us a
random port because we don't really care
okay all we like the only reason we need
these two will do on the reason we need
the server address and the I sorry the
only reason we need the IP address on
the port which is in other words the
server address is because we actually
want to or the server address and the
port yeah is because we actually want to
connect to the server okay that's it so
we haven't done any connecting yet we've
just created a mailbox or a socket
ideally now what we want to do is
actually try and send the data so again
we try and send it to the server address
in the port doesn't work out we weren't
really knowing which is why we kind of
made that acknowledgement so what we'll
do here is we will attempt to basically
send a connection packet okay which will
be private void send connection packet
now this is going to format some kind of
package I'm gonna be really simple with
this I'm just gonna say we have our data
which is going to be as simple as for
now maybe we'll send connection packet
again obviously that's a huge waste of
like bandwidth and everything because
it's huge we could probably send
something like some kind of code
or something like really simple and
probably not a string but anyway this
will be as good as we really need to be
for now as in this is a good test
and of course we'll send that data and
it knows exactly where to send it to now
assuming we get that successfully which
we probably will
which do two things first of all we
definitely need to make sure that we're
sending this on a different thread but
we'll talk about that next time and the
other thing will be we need to obviously
really hopefully receive something but
we don't really care about that right
now
and the more return true if that's
successful again we don't know if it's
successful yet but what we're going to
do here is wait for server to reply
which again we'll talk about next time
however we've done all this work so
let's at least test it out and the way
we're gonna test it out is by our doing
two things first of all back in my game
I believe I left a to-do saying connect
to server here so let's try that out
we'll say client client again we'll just
do this all sandbox in here for now
client clinicals new client we'll try
the normal way first so I'll still do
localhost
however the port I believe would was
like 8 1 9 2 because that is my favorite
port of all time for some reason yep so
the port that the server is running on
is 8 1 9 2 by reading the rain server
class so we'll stick that in first 8 1 9
2 ok and then if possible do client
document okay so how we're gonna know if
is connect well first of all we're gonna
run this and we're gonna see if we get
any exceptions now we shouldn't get
anything at all but let's just see what
happens ok game runs normally nothing
complains fantastic now let's start the
server and specifically I believe we
might have no no we didn't okay so what
we'll do now is in the process method
for now here's we're going to do so we
have the data this is back in the server
class of course right server class we
have our process data ground packet
we're going to ignore the rest of this
stuff so a good way to easily ignore it
is just say if true return if you just
write return Java will not let you
compile the code for some reason so you
have to write if true return and that's
basically just an the same as commenting
out the rest of this code it's just a
bit easier because we don't actually
want to process this yet so we have the
data the other thing I'll get there
is the address which is going to be
packaged at address and then finally the
port we also want to know the port of
where it came from
packet I've get bought ok so that's what
I meant by when you send a letter you
have your return address on it right
packets also have that packets have the
actual data which is the contents and
then they also have where they came from
that's very important because of course
we did start our client on a random port
so even if we somehow know the IP
address of the client we don't know the
port ok there's no way to know I mean
not that you would in a real world
scenario you wouldn't know the IP
address of your clients anyway right as
in like before they connect you have no
idea who's going to connect right when
they connect you can see what IP address
connected thus you have their IP address
and port so you can send them back data
but obviously you're not going to know
like in this case we know that the IP
address of the client is gonna be
localhost because I'm running out on the
same thing but of course in a real world
scenario you wouldn't know so it's
obviously vital for the packets to
contain that information and for us to
have it so what we'll do is easily what
we'll just as a debugging thing we'll
we'll kind of do a print packet thing or
I'll just do dump packet okay and what
dump packet will do is it will basically
take in I mean I guess we can just take
in the packet this is what we need from
it though
ok so I'll quickly copy that and write a
method here probably I'll do at the end
so we'll how like all our debug methods
at the end private void dump packets and
we'll have a diagram packet that's a
socket okay these are all the that's
basically the information I wanted um
and then we'll basically just say it may
be something like packets and then we'll
have an IP address and a port so the way
we'll do this is I'll just do a little
tab here so that it shifts it along and
it looks nice
I might even because I'm like being
fancy I might even do something like
that at the beginning and at the end
because you know printing is fun
will do plus our dress dot gets it's a
good kind of get hostname get her to
dress this is the IP address in the
string format that's kind of what I want
plus and then we'll do the port okay so
we have that set up and then of course
we might as well kind of print the the
data an easy way to do this probably I
mean we know that we received a string
so we could easily just do something
like I'll do this
so contents and I might do just an extra
print line here okay Eclipse just null
pointer exceptions itself that's fun
anyway hopefully that wasn't like too
bad then of course for the contents for
example we can do and maybe I might even
two tabs here I'll just for now I'll
grab that byte array and I'll convert it
into a string okay and then hopefully
like that will be kind of okay I mean in
this case it will be but of course in
other cases when we send raw data which
will have like you know zeros in it null
termination characters this is not a
good way to print you know bytes of data
hmm but in this case that we find so
we're dumping our packet and that is
good and then of course we will need
this because we need to like when we
take in the process we want to know
which client came from so that of course
we can tell all the other clients
connected for example which player has
moved to where okay important stuff okay
I'm 26 minutes wasn't it 16 minutes like
a second ago Oh Mike making these videos
between 10 to 20 minutes long is
absolutely impossible I should stop
wasting time sorry this is the worse
okay sorry anyway back to this um where
were we
yes so receiving okay so hopeful
now if we stop the server which I'm
going to do by just being like you know
a debugger has java application I guess
and hopefully that means I've started
we're not even printing anything but
hopefully the server is listening what
I'm gonna do now is I want to start the
client and then hopefully the server
should print that you know connection
packet text that we sent so what am I
looking for debug a driver application
and look okay let's maybe okay let's
just close the client now in the debug
tab we want to switch over to the server
which is still running and then
hopefully awesome what you can see in
the console in the for the server as you
can see this is the service console it
says packet from this IP address and
this port so that is the localhost IP
address of course that is a random port
that is that it has assigned and the
contents of this packet our connection
packet which is exactly what we sent
fantastic okay there we go so you can
see how that's working now without
sending information and this will
theoretically as long as like it's
allowed through firewall and everything
work all around the world right as in if
I had another computer somewhere on my
local network or on an external network
and whatever it would theoretically work
as long as I started my server on that
and the server was allowed through
firewall and it was like the ports were
forwarded correctly on your router and
everything theoretically if you did that
and then you from another computer
somewhere in the world tried to connect
to that IP address in that port then you
would be able to send out to it okay so
that is now working and that that is a
good place to wrap up the episode so
thanks for watching guys hope you
enjoyed this video if you did please hit
the like button leave any questions you
may have in the comment section below
I'll try and write them down and answer
them in the next video or just reply to
them via YouTube if you want to support
the series and get the source code all
the source code is available on this
game programming repository which is a
private github repository with every
with every episode as you can see
there's like a separate commit so you
can see like exactly what has changed
since the last episode and all that
stuff if you want access to this all you
have to do is support me on patreon if
you pledge $5 or more per month which is
like I mean what that's like a cup of
coffee or two right I mean not a big
deal if you plan to that you receive you
receive all its code for the game
programming series so that you can make
sure that you're writing the right at
the correct code and of course by doing
so not only do you receive the code you
also support me meaning I can continue
making these videos so anyway thanks for
watching guys I hope you enjoyed this
video and I'll see you guys next week
with another of game programming episode
goodbye